[Music]
Ted Morgan explores the history of
anti-communist sentiment in the United
States in his new book Reds McCarthyism
in twentieth-century America this
history on book TV feature from the
Eisenhower Institute in Washington DC is
about 50 minutes good evening welcome to
the Eisenhower Institute for our next in
our series of book events featuring Ted
Morgan's book on Reds McCarthyism in the
20th century 20th century America
forgive me welcome I don't know how have
you been to our events before but our
format here is there'll be a
presentation first and then there'll be
a question and answer period afterwards
and at the end of that there'll be an
opportunity to get some signed copies of
the books also use this opportunity to
let you all know that we are going to
have our annual dinner in April April
28th at the Ronald Reagan's center here
across the way at the Ron Reagan
International Trade Center I should say
and those of you who are on our mailing
list you're in good stead but please
when you go out mark down in the
guestbook outside or leave a business
card so we can let you know about the
future book events and the dinner and
also that way we can get invitations to
you with the dinner etc those of you who
may not know Ted Morgan has written
several books books on the American
expansion to the west on Churchill which
is the first book of his I read myself
an FDR and the latest book on
McCarthyism in America neatly dovetails
with the Eisenhower mission it both just
discusses a current issue which is on
suppression of free speech I guess is
the best way of putting it
and it also dovetails back to something
that was rooted in the era in which
Eisenhower was president
custom year is not really to primp the
the speaker but let me just say that
President Eisenhower himself felt very
strongly about Senator McCarthy of
course people like Beatle Smith his
chief of staff of course George C
Marshall were assaulted in through the
Senators accusations over time and he
was in a position in the White House
where he felt he could not respond
directly to what was happening up at the
Senate of course and the best way to put
it is that his general good pastor was
reminding me today he didn't feel it was
proper for the president United States
to get in the gutter with the senator
Hill is better for the Senate itself to
take care of what was happening up there
the book if you've not had a chance to
read it is phenomenal it's a wonderful
read it covers the whole period from the
time of the Russian Revolution onward
and really makes a strong argument for
how rooted what the phenomena that we
now know call McCarthyism was in the
United States throughout that period and
how various political figures exploited
that to their best to for political game
and without further ado I'd like to
introduce Ted Morgan thank you very much
[Applause]
I'm particularly pleased to be with you
today because when I was writing this
book I was fascinated fascinated by the
way Truman and Eisenhower handled
McCarthy whose career as a red hunter
overlapped their presidencies when
McCarthy gave his wheeling speech in
February 1950 attacking Truman's
administration for harboring communists
in the State Department the president
was blindsided at a difficult time in
1949 Mao Zedong had taken control of
China and the Soviets exploded their
first nuclear bomb a month before
McCarthy speech Alger Hiss was convicted
confirming suspicions that there had
been Soviet spies in government as
Richard Nixon later wrote it was the
hiss case that completely changed the
public's perception on domestic
communism Truman saw McCarthy is a
stalking horse for the Republican Party
which had been out of power since 1933
being confrontational by nature he
counter-attacked in his press
conferences On February 16 Truman
snapped that quote there was not a word
of truth unquote in McCarthy's charges
on March 30 Truman called McCarthy quote
the Kremlin's best asset unquote but for
a sitting president to trade punches
with an unprincipled demagogue was not a
sound tactic Truman's invective only
only invigorated McCarthy and his
followers On June 14 1951 on the Senate
floor
McCarthy delivered a 72,000 word tirade
against Eisenhower's mentor George C
Marshall Ike who was then in Paris as
commander-in-chief of NATO wrote in his
diary on that day that McCarthy was
a disciple of hate the following year
when he was running for president
Eisenhower had to show that he
disapproved of McCarthy's tactics while
trying to hold together a Republican
majority Republican party whose right
wing it admired so having McCarthy in
the tent who was worse than having him
outside looking in and i could' want to
say anything that would split the party
but when he went to wisconsin on the
campaign trail in the fall of 52 he told
his speechwriter image on who's to
insert a defensive marshal in his
Milwaukee speech once in Wisconsin in
early October where I could been joined
on the train by McCarthy the paragraph
about marshal was mysteriously dropped
in McCarthy's hometown of Appleton Joe
introduced Eisenhower who said the
country needed quote every single man on
the ticket here in Wisconsin from the
governor himself through the Senate in
the house unquote Ike was reprimanded in
the press for abandoning his expected
defense of marshal Truman who was then
campaigning for Adelaide Stevenson hit
the roof on October 10 and Utica Truman
said that Eisenhower quote knows that
general Marshalls patriotism is above
question he knows how completely
dishonest Joe McCarthy is he ought to
despise McCarthy now in his bid for
votes he has endorsed Joe McCarthy for
re-election I have never thought the man
who is now Republican the Republican
candidate would stoop so low
unquote over the years the deletion of
the marshal paragraph has become the
symbol of Eisenhower's unwillingness to
come to grips with McCarthy obviously
political necessity was a factor but
there was another reason and it had to
do with his old friend in wartime chief
chief of staff Walter Bedell Smith
who in 1950 had been named by Truman to
be director of the Central Intelligence
Agency Bedell Smith was a friend of
Senator William Benton of Connecticut
who McCarthy had sued for libel in
September 1952 Bedell Smith gave his
deposition in the libel case in the
course of which in his blunt and
soldierly ways he made a damaging
omission I know there were communists in
the State Department he said I believe
they're communists in my own
organization coming less than two months
before the election
Bedell Smith's comments made headlines
here was the head of intelligence in the
Truman administration appearing to
corroborate McCarthy's allegations about
communists and government in addition he
was a close friend of the Republican
candidate a mortified Walter Bedell
Smith called Eisenhower on September 30
and said it would be deplorable if the
CIA was used for political capital a
month before the election he was being
accused of disloyalty to Truman because
of his close association with Ike I
cannot stomach this implication of
disloyalty he said Walter Bedell Smith
regularly saw the FBI liaison agent with
the CIA Sanpei pitch for private shots
an FBI memo on October 8 1952 from pay
pitch to J Edgar Hoover recounted that
Bedell Smith had told pay Pitts quote
that's what happens when you talk too
much
unquote Bedell Smith said that he'd
placed himself in a jam
but that Ike had gotten him off the hook
by instructing that Smith's remarks not
be used in any Republican speeches the
congresswoman Clare Boothe Luce Smith
told paper she had wanted to give
Smith's
remarks and prominence in a radio talk
on Truman and communism but was told to
keep a lid on it on the occasion of
Eisenhower's recent talks in Wisconsin
the FBI memo went on Eisenhower had
planned to make complimentary references
to general Marshall but he refrained
from doing so after McCarthy agreed not
to make any references to Smith's
testimony in Washington Ike had
generously saved his old friends hide by
muzzling McCarthy in exchange for which
he cut out the Marshall paragraph in his
Milwaukee speech on October 3 after he
was elected Eisenhower moved his old
comrade-in-arms from the CIA to the
State Department as assistant secretary
once elected Eisenhower refused to clash
openly with McCarthy as Truman had
knowing that he would only magnify those
importance he refused to deal in
personalities and never cited McCarthy
by name but acted against him in hidden
ways as a result a number of writers
have faulted Ike for not being forceful
enough Robert Griffith and his respected
the politics of fear wrote that quote
the new president was a decent man but
he possessed neither the ability nor the
inclination to deal with a political
problem of this complexity urged by
friends and advisers to speak out
against McCarthy he often replied I just
will not get into the gutter with that
guy but although I did not get into the
gutter and despite Griffiths appraisal
Ike was instrumental in engineering
McCarthy's demise in the fall of 1953
McCarthy launched his investigation of
Army installations he insulted General
Ralph Zwicker who had
the first wave on d-day saying that he
was not fit to wear the uniform and that
he had the brains of a five-year-old at
that time the White House learned the
McCarthy's chief counsel Roy Cohn was
applying was applying improper pressure
on the army to gain favorable treatment
for his friend David shine who had been
drafted
Eisenhower acted through a surrogate his
confidant and delegate to the UN Henry
Cabot Lodge
On February 24 1954 large called
Secretary of the army Robert Stevens and
explained that McCarthy's army hearings
were in reality quote an attempt to
destroy the president politically there
was no doubt about it
he is speaking on the army because
Eisenhower was in the army this is
basically an attempt to destroy
Eisenhower the same crowd that supported
Taft at the 1952 convention are now
revolving around Joe launch said that
Ike had asked him to call Stevens and
tell him to draft a report on David
shine and favoritism Lodge said you have
that documentation there on boy s and I
think you ought to get that in shape for
publication we are doing that Stevens
replied that would be a devastating
thing launch said largest telephone call
on February 24 was the turning point
that led to the army McCarthy hearings
and the sensor and fall of McCarthy in
the televised hearings and thanks in
part to the brilliant tactics of the
army lawyer Joseph Nye Welsh McCarthy
self-destructed Charles Potter a
moderate Republican senator from
Michigan who had lost both legs to a
German artillery shell
it was Ikes eyes and ears on the
committee that held the hearings on May
3 he went to the White House to brief
the president it would be funny if it
was not so degrading Potter said it all
depends on what Joe happens to be
thinking at the time or maybe it depends
on the phases of the Moon Ike said
psychopathic yes Eisenhower had been
saying all along that only the Senate
could punish one of its own on December
2 1954 he was proven right when McCarthy
was censured for contempt by a vote of
67 to 22 the 22 who were against censure
made up about half the Republicans in
the Senate
ayuk strategy had paid off while
Truman's method of matching McCarthy
punch for punch had made the problem
worse Ike however was not sure that
censor was enough writing his friend
cliff Roberts on December 7 that quote
the number of senators who voted against
censor indicates that the so-called
splinter group may constitute almost
half the party McCarthy is operating at
the same old stand unquote
although diminished and discredited
McCarthy was not completely defined in
March 1955 Joe wrote the president an
abusive letter for not obtaining the
release of 11 us Airmen held by
Communist China which I can or in his
diary entry on March 11 i express
secretary jim hegarty
wrote all of us on the staff including
the president will make it a point not
to have any comment whatsoever on
anything McCarthy says or does
we have been relegated to the back pages
of the papers and he knows he is not
news anymore
McCarthy's last stand against the
President of his own
party came before the Geneva summit
conference of 1955 which would signal a
thaw in the Cold War anathema to Jo on
June 20 he went before the Foreign
Relations Committee to demand a Senate
resolution that the fate of the
satellite nations be discussed at the
summit
although Ike was perfectly willing to
raise the issue he did not appreciate
McCarthy giving the order vice-president
Nixon told Ike not to take McCarthy
seriously Ike said there was a story
going around Washington it's no longer
McCarthyism its McCarthy wasn't in the
debate in the full Senate on McCarthy's
resolution a few days later Majority
Leader Lyndon Johnson said the issue is
very simple it is whether the President
of the United States shall be sent to
Geneva with a gun at his head
McCarthy watched dumbfounded as his
one-time allies on the Republican right
JumpShip steadfast McCarthyite such as
Bork Hickenlooper of Iowa William Jenner
of Indiana and Herman Welker of Idaho
who was known as McCarthy jr. all
soldered with the president the Senate
vote against the resolution was 77 to 4
which left McCarthy virtually isolated
McCarthy kept writing the occasional
angry letter to Ike who kept ignoring
his communications and show lived long
enough to see Eisenhower elected to a
second term he attended Eisenhower's
inauguration on January 21 1957 in April
Jo was admitted to the cessna naval
hospital with a severe ailment on May 2
he died of acute alcoholism he was 48
years old thank you
[Applause]
you point to the origin you begin your
story back at the time the first world
warrior what would you say to expand
your thesis a bit to include the pre
warrior where the fear was of not
communism so much as socialism and labor
unrest man thinking back to the
Haymarket riots and other things in the
1880s do you see this is a Greek cursor
to what will become a Parthi ism yes
because there's always it is always the
line of reacting to a perceived threat
and or overreacting and trying to
understand and in those those early
years that you were talking about it's
very interesting to note that the the
first congressional investigation of
communism was in 1919 before there was
an American Communist Party so when you
go through the transcript of that
hearing you have these senators they
don't really know what Bolshevism is
they heard about it you know and it's
all new to them and you have one senator
from Delaware asking one of the witness
on read was one of the witnesses he was
back from Russia he witnesses revolution
and the senator from Delaware says well
are you saying that they relocate people
without their permission and I mean
either I live in Delaware and if I had
to go someplace else it'd be a hell of a
stink you know and so you see the
Senators grappling with this completely
baffling system you know that's taken
hold and
so I just follow the thread you know and
then there's a greater understanding and
but if you take it from the beginning
it's a it's it's fascinating to see
something's you know the the Congress
for the first time coming to grips with
something that the is just beyond their
comprehension yeah I was in the State
Department in those years that you were
describing I have a question
Beetle Smith was right as the Venona
transcript indicated as they slowly
became available but my question is sure
research ever showed whether Eisenhower
was briefed on the vanilla transcripts
and knew about that infiltration that
the intelligence folks didn't know well
certainly he was kept informed by J
Edgar Hoover and George Szell C and his
own national security team about
domestic communism but the interesting
thing there is that by the time
Eisenhower became president was
inaugurated in 53 the the American party
had gone through some some a very bad
period and lost a considerable part of
its membership and the Espionage system
the prospered during the war and even
under Truman had been pretty much
dismantled by the testimony of Whittaker
Chambers and Elizabeth Bentley so while
when during the period that Eisenhower
was president the espionage networks had
been more or less shut down domestic
communism was not that great a problem
and
I didn't how her dealt with it on the on
a cold war front and ended the war in
Korea and so on but in the United States
it wasn't a priority under his
administration hardly ever have a sense
of self doubt about what he was doing
and did he have a question the
consequences of what he was doing and -
do you think that the good that came out
of McCarthyism is the emphasis on a
pluralistic society that you hear echoed
throughout you know political rhetoric
ever since the 50s you know that it was
a terrible time but at the same time did
it make us have to really understand who
we are and what we value as important
well did he have a sense of self doubt
it's not apparent because because he was
he was he was a sort of a perpetual
motion machine you know and he was
always always on the go and always on to
the next the next hearing and he carried
a bunch of blank subpoenas in his a
briefcase and he so the the the meant
the material that's available chosen
very combative always involved in in
battles you know struggles so that the
self-doubt element you don't see it as
to his role in a in a pluralistic
society
they're very that's a very big question
because you have to see what the for
instance the role of the media was and
one of the things that struck me was
that the the executive sessions of this
committee were released last summer by
Congress and what you see there is that
he calls in witnesses into these
executive committees which are secret
and whether the president allowed and he
questions the witness sort of a dress
rehearsal for the regular hearing but
when the the the press is always waiting
for him when he comes out of the
committee room and so he tells him a
story which may be the exact opposite
that would happen in the executive
hearing and then they'd go out and
printed it you know so that there's a
role of the media in here that's very
important of not I don't think they were
scrupulous enough in simply repeating
whatever McCarthy said and as to the
awakening the the American public to
certain dangers I think there was a lag
in public perception that because of the
the conviction of Alger Hiss and the
information about all those spies the
public became alarmed about a situation
that really no longer existed because by
the by 1950 if you look at the Venona
files the KGB station chief in
washington is is cabling moscow and
saying our apparatus have been
completely dismantled by by by the
Bentley and chambers testimony so
there's a sort of lag and perception
between something that was a danger but
no longer really is
in Maryland and the first memory really
vigorous memory that I can recall of a
national event where's miss chambers
because my mother had gone to school was
a classmate Alger Hiss and my father who
was in the agricultural business new
chambers because you know the cattle
farm near Westminster and the arguments
were ferocious in their house and then
two years later miller-tydings who was a
very respected senator in Maryland was
really you know vicious campaign knocked
him out and my question to you on that
era would miller-tydings have fared
better had he been in the Senate
Eisenhower was president as opposed to
the confrontational give him hell Harry
well miller-tydings lost his Senate seat
as a result of campaign of the campaign
there was largely orchestrated by by
McCarthy where he had that composite
photograph of Earl Browder and
miller-tydings and so on yeah the the
tidings committee if you look at it
closely was it was an attempt to destroy
McCarthy and and Truman was involved but
it didn't do its job in a very full
manner and there was a question of
whether the Senators would be allowed to
look at the testimony from the security
files and Truman did agree to let three
or four senators go and look at it but
if you've ever looked at raw FBI files
you could sit there all day and you you
know it would take weeks to go through
it and they had a deadline and so they
did a very perfunctory job of going
through the files and then they came
back and so that the whole the tidings
committee was a an early and
unfortunately botched attempt to go
after McCarthy and it cost it eventually
costs tilings a seat what was the
interplay with the jail of stone at this
time what was jail of stone no stone was
a former communist who was in the AFL
and who was involved in setting up
anti-communist unions in Europe so that
was really on the labor front but he was
connected they knew various presidents
and had a role but he acted through the
AFL two administration's come longer
internationally from McCarthy earrings
and the core these currents on it was an
enormous amount of pressure in the sense
that in Europe NATO allies were
constantly saying that McCarthy it was a
terrible threat to peace and democracy
so the ambassadors would if you look at
the correspondence from the ambassador's
from the various capital they say can't
you do something about McCarthy I mean
we're getting criticized all the time
and so on and so forth and then of
course when when she cone and shine went
to Europe on their famous trip to look
at the u.s. is libraries there I
remember there was one conversation with
the ambassador in Paris to told
salzburger who was Foreign Affairs
columnist for The Times these two guys
are going around talking to my people
and asking about V and my good
ambassador so so they they managed to
turn everybody against the
allusion to a Nixon eisenhower
conversation that ISM wasn't like that
you mentioned what about earlier that is
during the campaign
Nixon's rice bowl had become any
communism how did he and Eisenhower
interact on the issue of McCarthy is
there any how the necks of them yes did
it make them uncomfortable and talking
about it well you know Nixon had been
the one who had sort of walked Whittaker
Whittaker Chambers through his paces and
he'd done quite a scrupulous job and of
course at that time Truman was still
president and Truman gave the famous
press conference when he called it all a
red herring because he saw it simply as
in a Republican attack he didn't think
that the Espionage issue was important I
think he was wrong there and so he tried
to he actually tried to have members of
his staff dig up some dirt on chambers
that had been in a in an insane asylum
and so on so forth and Nixon did a very
scrupulous job and and this was
eventually convicted but I'm trying to
think of exchangers at Nixon and
Eisenhower had on on the I don't know
that they discuss it that much except in
the context of McCarthy now and then and
there's nothing that sticks out in my
mind that they had long talks about it
or anything like that
and Eisenhower of course acted at the
time he person
of the army McCarthy hearings and but
before then he was very circumspect he
would make general statements and press
conferences that there are certain
tactics that we shouldn't be using that
he never mentioned McCarthy by name and
like and I can't really remember
anything and he anything more specific
between Nixon and I'm sure there is I
just don't have it in my head was the
attempt to undermine Eisenhower simply
gratuitous or did he have presidential
ambitions himself well Eisenhower
thought he had presidential ambitions
and for a while and during the 52
campaign McCarthy's star was rising and
he was being summoned by other senators
to help out in their campaigns so he
thought of himself as in great demand
and possibly presidential and Eisenhower
thought he was presidential but it
happened very fast because you had the
the election you had and then in 53
McCarthy started his own investigations
which came up with very little and in 54
was the army McCarthy so his star rose
and then it fell it happened very fast
what is the perception you think of
McCarthyism today and other any
consequences for today's politics or
policy are it's all been pretty much
forgotten no I think it continues all
the time I think that when you have when
you use tactics let's say the politics
of fear you know like McCarthy got
everybody scared about the extent of of
communism in the United States at a time
when when when the danger of communism
was substantially less and now we were
scared to death after 9/11 and it led to
an invasion of Iraq and and now all the
assumptions that we had for going to or
being questioned and it's all complete
hornet's nest you know so you see these
tendencies reappearing fear of communism
was substantially less than when was it
substantial oh it was substantial
actually it hit the high point during
World War two when we had 15,000 Russian
experts in this country invited by
lend-lease defense factories some of
them who they were they bought PT boats
for the Russian Navy they were down in
Tampa and it got into the PT boats and
flew and and sailed them all the way to
Russia and so there was a lot of
espionage going on during the war and
that's when the Venona transcripts the
decoding began and we began to see the
extent of it now as there was of course
you didn't decode everything right away
and by 1950 they decoded enough so that
they'd exposed the Rosenberg ring Alger
Hiss Plenty's plenty of others in
government departments so by the time
McCarthy came on the scene all that was
over and the KGB was saying we don't
have anybody left because they also lost
the the ideological recruiting method
you know of saying we're we're allies
why shouldn't you help the Russians you
know we're all in this together so the
ideological reason was gone the agents
were gone I was like the opening of the
KGB files after the fall of the Soviet
Union put a new cloth on any of this
activity and put in a different
perspective
normos you know first of all you do
there - there's the Venona files which
were decoded here which were released
only in 1995 and which gave the
transcripts of all they met they decoded
about 10,000 messages which was only in
fact about 10% of the total because they
had five different codes and but just
from what they had they got they they
were able to identify the code names and
to get the names of the actual spies I
mean there's enormous of difference and
then the the other the other papers that
were were released by in Moscow and I
did research there with with the Yale
historians who were he was actually
financed by Yale to get to get those
files going again and have they didn't
have copying machines I didn't have
microfilm or anything and so there was a
lot of material there - it's enormous
amount
review your conclusions on the reasons
Eisenhower agreed to drop the paragraph
on George Marshall prior to the
Milwaukee speech I heard some very
interesting new and information about
Beetle Smith there they were you saying
that there was a quid pro quo and
Eisenhower voluntarily took him out
absolutely and it comes out in that FBI
memo where Bedell Smith told the FBI
liaison that Eisenhower agreed to drop
the paragraph if if McCarthy would
refrain from saying anything about
Bedell Smith remarks about had there
being communists in the government in
the CIA related to because I have gone
through all of the papers in Abilene in
each of the drafts and I believe okay
okay one of those today no I just
weren't because you know business the
date of that
FBI memo October 8 1952 that's the
sandpaper sugar question as you go
through the drafts the the taking out of
the paragraph looks like a sudden act
with eisenhower a pencil you know taking
it down vertically horizontally across
the page and everything like okay you
guys I give in I'm going to take it out
it doesn't it was in for so many drafts
I've just curious on the timing on it
that's all thank you October 8th that's
the months months before the election
[Music]
told me that President Eisenhower
regretted that for the rest of his life
okay I can't hear you sorry general
Goodpaster told me that general he
thinks general eisenhower regretted
taking that paragraph out for the rest
of his life
could be no I'm not saying that was the
only reason that the sister saving
Bedell Smith hide was the only reason he
was also under pressure from McCarthy
who was on the train from governor
kohler wisconsin who was on the train
they were all telling him that don't
don't do this and there's a well-known
exchange where mccarthy tells eisenhower
if you if you leave that end you'll be
booed and an Eisenhower said I've been
booed before so this was an ongoing
discussion that was going on
they took through they got on the train
in Peoria and they went sort of
Wisconsin had plenty of time to discuss
[Music]
to make sure we're never within X feet
of each other so the pictures could be
taken to the two of them together and I
was government power who said the way
mal described it was Laird you're in
deep trouble if they get near each other
there's much more in that FBI memo that
I didn't quote and it ends with by
saying that Bedell Smith says that
Eisenhower and McCarthy will never get
along something like that
and for clarification of course while
the paragraph was taken out President
Eisenhower obviously defended general
Marshall and numerous occasions after
that point so there was a greater
context to this that he left it out that
corn of course was critical but he took
numerous opportunities to try to set the
record straight for every one of
Marshall service and patriotism of
course of course it had been Truman's
responsibility more directly because
Marshall that's true in a Secretary of
State and the instigator of the Marshall
Plan by the time
Eisenhower came to office Marshall had
resigned but he did say in his diary
that because he was a disciple of hate
covers not just the McCarthy era itself
but the whole sweep of this use of hate
and fear for political gain and you
didn't have an opportunity much of an
opportunity here to talk about that you
mentioned send to step back in 1919 and
all in the first war but an important
portion of your book of course is the
last portion where your and you made
reference to it of the post 9/11
incidents of this sort of use which is
obviously a debate there over what is
the current national emergency where
does this fit into that could you
address that and what what the current
context is and how they didn't may
differ from the McCarthy era itself well
I mean it differs in the sense that
we're no longer concerned with communism
and we're concerned with terrorism which
was a is a genuine threat it's not
made-up we're where the element of
McCarthyism might enter into it as in
the argument that's been made
that we would have been better off
attacking Afghanistan where we knew the
terrorists were and instead of going
into this absolute bedlam of Iraq where
we still are and we don't know how we're
gonna get out and we're losing men every
day and you know so the arguments along
those lines the numbers in that Senate
censure and the point about McCarthy act
being upwards of a at least half of the
party at that particular stage would you
elaborate on this a little bit I mean I
think it's fast I mean the most
fascinating part of this to me is the
fact that the Republican Party was bent
on destroying its own president or at
least part of the party was was this all
about McCarthyism or was this being used
as a you know one issue when in fact
there were there was a numerous of
jeanna genders here for that group that
supported McCarthy over the president
yeah that's an interesting point because
when when Eisenhower makes that
statement after the censer and he's
worried that the what they call the taft
wing of the party was still intact and
would continue to to attack him and that
they might seek maneuver to have another
candidate and in the 56 election but
what's him what's interesting is that by
55 with the election a year away and and
in the post-mortem after the sensor
things that changed dramatically and and
that's why I
i evoke that that business of the Geneva
summit because that's where McCarthy's
alone and and and and and the the
right-wing with an election a year away
is rallying around so it's timing is so
important wonder those days right about
the fact the irony that they had just
spent what four or five years fighting a
war of a tyrant filled with fear and
hate and then here five years later on
our own soil
someone has so much power with fear at
you know basements fear and hate I mean
were people making those kind of
comparisons in those days or was the
only history in years later that we
could see that well it had a lot to do
with a cold war context the loss of
China launched a whole movement you know
how did we lose China we must have lost
China because we had we would be trade
and so on and so forth and then you had
events like Bolin's confirmation and
Secretary of State and then they brought
up he also you know we were betrayed at
Yalta so there's this kind of lagging
perception that there was something
rotten somewhere you know and then so it
all rallied around the figure of
McCarthy
[Applause]
thank you very much for coming and
they'll be an opportunity to get some
books signed out here and to learn more
about what we do here at the Institute
there's some information out there but
also please visit our website which will
also tell you something about our dinner
which is the Eisenhower institute.org
thank you very much Ted Morgan is the
author of Reds McCarthyism in 20th
century America it's published by Random
House on the web at Random House com
next week on history on book TV
Einsteins